hey wait a minute that's not true Tony
because the shelter no got to be a whole
lot more when she actually joined their
rehearsal and furry
it was definitely company yeah you know
what they look ready to go for Monday's
premiere Suzanne is not even letting her
legendary love life slow down one two
three there is this old wives tale that
says sex saps your strength
thank you see I love that and it's been
known you said you got a healthy sex
life but the husband maybe a couple
times a day this whole thing about as
you get older you lose your sex drive
no do you cut back have you told her
food is not cut back and if they miss a
day they make up for it in a weekend no
but what I keep wanting to explain is
maybe it's twice a day but I'm not awake
for the first grade Suzanne's comic
timing it's still there I mean we first
saw 38 years ago when three's company
debuted greatest job I ever had
can you sing any of the theme song karma
knock on my door and here's some trivia
that Suzanne in a brunette wig during
that theme will there be any sort of Nod
to Three's Company we all have the theme
songs still in our head yes
I gotta give the fans what they're
looking for for a while no say
my son point there's gonna be something
a tribute to that because that show
meant so much to so many people and you
learn to speak English yes I actually
did learn how to speak English watching
her show so anything I may make
grammatical mistakes it's her fault at
68 Suzanne is older than all the seven
of the 236 contestants Dancing's ever
had but she's not feeling it
so 68 is the new 25 I can tell you from
my own personal experience I would say
that 68 could be easily between 25 and
30 the way this woman dances amazing
grandmother of six listen if this is
what 68 looks like sign me or you could
sign up for her book list Suzanne's
written a whopping ten self-help books
ten diet books two autobiographies and
one book of poetry I think because of
all these books I've written to women
about there's a new way in age and it's
not about the number it's about your
energy and vitality and I wanted to
prove to me in to them that it ain't
over love it